[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney host of the dr john dolone show
is my co-host today as we talk about
your life and your money it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two dr deloney if you
aren't aware has an unbelievably popular
show on podcast on uh of course youtube
and you can call into his show and be a
part of it or you can call him today if
you've got questions about mental health
anxiety boundaries relationships and all
that stuff generally pops up on the show
anyway so we're here to help you with
your life
and with your money triple eight eight
two five five two two five chelsea is
with us chelsea is in jacksonville
florida hi chelsea how are you
uh hi i'm doing good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um i just had a quick question first off
thank you for your show and your
principles and everything i cry every
time i watch a debt free scream i can't
help it me too i've been doing it 30
years
um i had a quick question so my husband
and i are on baby step three all of our
debt is paid off we paid off
the harley in december and that was the
last of our car payments and any of our
debt
we currently have our second baby on the
way
due in
february and
my husband recently proposed the idea of
selling the bike
and i don't know how i feel about it
because i bought it for him
as a wedding gift um
and
i've been trying again to sell the truck
for years but i never thought he would
go
for selling the motorcycle um
so i guess i'm just wondering what you
think
hmm
does he want to sell it for money
yeah just just sell it for cash i think
he's
maybe thinking more about
uh
you know
family and two kids and potential for
something bad to happen um so that's
what i was wondering is he is he trying
to sell it because you all need the cash
or is he trying to sell it because and
i've heard of this i've had buddies that
said
man i suddenly riding my motorcycle felt
selfish i got two little kids and i'm
i'm putting myself in a high risk
category right and so i'm gonna sell it
because of that
but it sounds like that's why he's
selling it i think that's where his
heart is i think he's just thinking
about it a little more he loves writing
it and i you know i feel bad him
thinking about it but now that he's
mentioned it now my
thoughts are churning and thinking about
well we could get our emergency fund
i'll say all [ __ ] up if he sold it and
so what's the call what's the bike worth
um it's a 09 soft kale i i looked online
maybe about 10 000. okay and what's the
uh two cars that you're driving worth
um
right now um he's got a truck and oh six
gmc
oh gosh i have no idea what they're
worth they're just
what's your household income
um household income is about 120. okay
so you can afford the bike you're out of
debt
you have an emergency fund you have a
ten thousand dollar toy in the garage
so this has absolutely nothing to do
with money
right has nothing to do with money
so then it comes down to why does he
want to sell it and are you okay with
that reason
if his reasoning is what john is saying
that he's going i got two kids this
feels i could lay this thing down leave
her with two kids i don't want to do
that it takes some of the joy out of the
bike
for now i'll i'll pick up a bike later
i'm an empty nester we'll buy two of
them and tour the world in them you know
and send the kids off to college and
whatever but if that's his reasoning um
if i'm in your shoes i feel pretty loved
yeah i do
he's a good man yeah
i mean if that's if that's his reasoning
i don't think he needs to sell it for
money
you're it's not you don't have a
financial reason to sell the bike
if it was a boat and it was ten thousand
dollars and it was in the garage
and you guys wanted to keep it and it's
a toy and you're out of debt and you
make 120 a year your total of all your
vehicles is less than half your annual
income which it definitely is
then you know you don't have too much
going on here with stuff that has wheels
and motors and you don't have a problem
um and so
you know it and ten thousand dollars
doesn't change your life in the positive
or the negative in your situation
because you've done such a good job on
all the other fronts
so i think it just comes down to what's
his motivation and are you okay with
that because i think his motivation is
forward-looking and your
sadness is
due to the nostalgia of you gave it to
him from the past and as a wedding gift
she was surprised that
he would ever sell
a gift that i gave him one time you know
what i mean yeah i get that a little bit
of that but yeah but it's a if if it's
you know we don't have him on the line
so we don't know what's driving this but
no pun intended but um
but yeah you just have to decide there
what's what's going to happen and so the
calls we usually take are the opposite
yeah is he won't sell it he's got three
kids and we need the money and he's
being reckless and it's a sixty five
thousand dollar bike you know and so
yeah that kind of stuff so i i'm with
you
my first thought is man if he's selling
it because he's starting to look forward
and thinking i i need to go take up golf
this guy's a stud i was gonna say yeah
what a good guy
tim is in grand rapids michigan hey tim
how are you
i'm great uh thanks dave uh john for
taking the call sure oh
well my question is uh my wife and i
will be on step four five and six um
within a month or so wonderful and
yeah we've been working hard on it um
we're behind in investing for retirement
for our age
how old are you and my question um we're
both 40.
whoopee and
yeah i guess uh yeah 40 isn't so bad but
you got plenty of time
okay um
i guess my question is is uh
should we do more than 15 of our income
no no
because i want the rest of it on your
house get your house paid off that's the
shortest distance to being a millionaire
that's
i was 70 sure you're going to say that
you should have been 79.99
or yeah no i mean yeah it's because
here's the thing if you run the math out
you know basically you're gonna use the
extra pile of money let's say you raised
it to 20
you're going to end up using that to pay
off the house anyway
so basically what you're doing is
investing in order to pay off the house
well so let's just go pal fast
okay well good we should
and we only own
94 000 oh good lord and what do you make
a year
uh gross is about 120. oh geez dude pay
your house off man you're gonna be a
baby steps millionaire by the time
you're 50.
and that that reduces the the retirement
liability you have if you have no no
house payment exactly ding ding yeah
which is one of the big reasons we push
you to get this done so average person
doing our stuff pays off their home in
seven and a half years
from time they start and they become a
baby steps millionaire on average in
about 12 or 14 years
and so
and the paid off house is a big chunk of
your net worth of course to determine
your millionaire status head off man
yeah yeah yeah yeah good call man thanks
for calling
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at aaa
825-5225
brian is with us brian is in denver hi
brian how are you
i'm good how are y'all better than i
deserve what's up
uh i just wanted to know if i should i
only work
four days a week
40 hours so that's all i can get until
november when it goes to five days a
week
but they shorten the hours till three
o'clock should i get a second job or use
that time to figure out you know
uh
side hustle or you know what my passion
is
uh are you working on getting out of
debt what's your financial support yeah
i'm on baby step two so okay so money
matters then right
yes so which one's gonna pay you the
most
uh
in the short term i'd say getting a
second job but in the long term
aside hustle you know you can
scale that indefinitely if you're good
at it
what's the side hustle
i hadn't figured that part out yet
so
i was
going i think there's some side hustles
that you could make more this month on
than working a part-time job
i mean you could you know if you decide
um i don't know i'll just make up
something let's say you you have
carpentry skills and you decide you're
gonna build decks
uh you make more doing that this month
than you can drive an uber
right
right but i mean because i mean you need
a hammer
and a saw
and get your button gear you know but if
you're starting a business that you're
going to have to invest in for month
after month after month after month and
it be six months before you start making
an income
then to your point yeah you probably
should take just a job because you need
the money right now to get out of debt
and i think the magic would be linking
the two yeah if you want to start a side
hustle building decks do you get a job
at home depot learning how that thing
works and talk to tradesmen and or if
you want to start an ice cream shop do
you get a second job at an ice cream
shop but it sounds like you're not there
yet sounds like you just need to get to
working and get some cash in your door
yeah but i mean there's a lot of side
hustle small business ideas that make
you more money than
going down and collecting minimum wage
somewhere and you can start them
tomorrow you can go mow lawns yeah
exactly yeah you'll make money
instantaneously i mean you get your leaf
blower rich people are afraid of leaves
they'll pay you to get rid of them
i haven't heard that it's jt is with us
jt is in spokane washington hi jt how
are you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i'm just at a bit of a crossroads
with my business right now and
struggling
to find out what my next move is
um basically
i'm swamped with work i'm just i'm super
busy i'm working
well over 40 hours a week
um
and the income that it's bringing in is
just the right amount
you know to put food on the table and
live
modestly right um
but i don't have any time to we need to
you know grow the income and uh
and grow the business and
and you know obviously just advance and
grow this thing
but um i just don't have any time
to market and really put a lot of time
into the business rather than just the
work
so i need to hire an employee but i
can't afford to drop my income by hiring
an employee
so i'm kind of at this limbo just
wondering okay how do i handle this and
what do i do
what do you do
i repair dental tools
you repair dental what
tools like the little
dental schools i thought wow dental
school
no tools of repair
those little itty bitty drills
those are so much
okay so if you had
10 hours a week freed up
you would spend that on marketing which
would result in more business correct
cuts now who would do the work when you
got more business
if you had that 10 hours a week freed up
well i would hire somebody and teach
them to do a portion of the work yeah
okay so here here's my point at this
stage of the game uh you are either
going to hire someone
to uh you're probably going to hire
someone and mentor them and show them
how to do the stuff and for a month or
so
how long will it take you to get them up
where they can do
some work without you watching
oh probably probably a month a month and
a half so you get you bring somebody on
board and you pay them for a month and
you make you make less
that month
by what you've paid them
okay because you got the same income
coming in you've got the same output
same number of drills being repaired
correct for that one month correct and
so you lose money that month
over where you are today but then the
next month
uh the new guy
you've now
uh
you can almost double your output
starting the next month so you're gonna
let him um
do half of the jobs
the next month and you're going to spend
that 20 hours out of 40 going and
getting new business
and you're going to spend the other 20
hours doing the repairs from the new
business that you came in and you're
going to make a lot more
in the second month if you can go get
more business
follow me
yeah yeah you're not going to be you're
not going to be a full-time marketer and
have one guy doing repairs because right
now you've got one guy doing repairs
that's that's your entire output you
have to increase your output of repairs
in addition to doing the marketing you
follow me
yeah and so you're going to be working
50 on
repairs
in this first phase now the next
employee that you hire
might get you out of the repair business
and full time into running the business
you got two guys completely cranking out
two people completely cranking out
repairs all day long and while you're
running the business in every sense okay
making sure supplies are in you're
getting new business in you're
making sure the payroll is paid um and
and it could be that you know that your
next part your third person might be an
administrative person
okay
so that that's kind of how i did it when
i started but here's the thing you have
to
take a step back to take these other
steps forward but what you want to do is
do it very systematically so that it's a
a very precise step so that it's you
don't want you don't want to go
and uh
it takes six months for this person to
get up to speed
on the repairs
because then you're making a lot less
money for six months that's going to
start to get really ouchy so it's
important to have some really clear
metrics on is this thing in 30 days or
60 days is this working or not yeah and
i'd want to know how much business is
actually is the business out there a
function of me not being able to go get
it or is it does it really not exist
yeah right yeah you got to know that
there's that many dental drills that you
can get your hands on to repair right
can you double is there enough business
out there that you can double your
volume right if you had a way to do it
yeah and um if not then you may need to
raise your prices that's exactly right
and that'll slow your business down too
and better give you an opportunity to
make relationships with these folks and
to
yeah if you're the only only gig in town
it seems like a really niche operation
there
yeah well there's a lot of dentists oh
yeah
and they all have lots of drills
it never ceases to amaze me there's so
many jobs i never knew existed yeah i
mean um
what a cool little business you know so
i was sitting with one of our guys at
lunch and he went to a birthday party
for his kids and a guy has a foam
machine have you seen these things
no they plug it into a tub full of soap
and it blows foam
four feet deep
across the park
and they give all the kids at the
birthday party goggles and they all run
into the phone
that's that's incredible it's like it's
a bubble machine that's all it is
and there's people in america unemployed
right now
and bubble boy is over here making a
fortune and what that guy does is he's
got a full-time job and he just does
this on saturdays i'm sure and he makes
more shows up with his machine he makes
more with his bubbles that's right
than some of you sitting around waiting
on your mama to fix it he doesn't even
clean up afterwards he just leaves
well the kids everybody's clean that's
the kids are clean yeah it's soap he's
cleaning the park for every road it's
for free he cleaned the park for free
guys there's a job out there for
everyone i'm just saying bubble boy can
figure it out that's everybody ought to
be able to figure it out
as long as there are garages in america
there should be no unemployment that's
exactly right this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the debt-free stage
right here at ramsey solutions lobby
tyler and erica are with us hey guys
where y'all from
johnson nebraska all right what's that
in there omaha so hour near omaha okay
well an hour's close in nebraska yeah so
uh how much debt have you guys paid off
uh 180
628 dollars all right 181 000 and your
range of income i'm sorry how long did
that take you 17 months and 23 days whoa
it was 181 128 180 181 81 and your range
of income during that time uh 77 000 to
100 000. okay so you didn't make 181 in
17 months so you must have sold
something big we sold a lot of stuff uh
we uh we sold we we moved we had a 150
000 loan on our house
and then we sold cars tractors trucks uh
household items i mean we had a hundred
and eight thousand dollars worth items
we sold oh my goodness wow and then uh
we
we wanted to move um to the uh to the
lincoln diocese catholic diocese in
nebraska to raise our family
and uh
so we we started looking around at
houses and we saw a sign that said you
know this divine mercy jesus that says
jesus i trust in you and that was our
sign yeah we needed to do this and and
so we uh
we uh
found a house in nebraska that we liked
we bought it in cash before we sold our
house in
oh my goodness and then uh we were
this is how uh how awesome this was uh
we were worried about you know we knew
we wanted to get down there but uh
we were worried about you know what job
are we gonna get and how are we gonna
sell the house well
we got a phone call from a friend
uh we didn't even list our house they
bought the house from us oh my god and
then i got a phone call from an old boss
of mine they wanted me to work for him
again
down in nebraska and so uh i didn't even
have to go looking for it all worked out
wonderfully so what do you do i'm a
engineer for hormel foods okay excellent
excellent very cool what about you erica
what do you do uh i was a special
education teacher but after we got
married then i was a stay-at-home mom
all right very fun good i worked briefly
over while we were paying off debt but
okay
so what that what was the hundred and
eighty one thousand dollars of debt on
so we had uh unsecured loan at twenty
thousand five hundred and eighty five
dollars for able that i did for a side
business
which helped us pay off debt
uh we had a credit card with six
thousand dollars that i used for new
concrete and a building we had and then
we had our home loan of 154 thousand
dollars okay
so and then you just sold everything in
sight everything
we we worked uh we sold we did this
plasma business uh selling decorative
signs and mechanical parts and then my
wife worked at home depot uh to just we
were able to get our i mean you guys
just exploded like 17 months ago yeah
you changed jobs you changed cities you
changed your life yeah what in the world
happened 17 months ago that set you on
fire like this uh we just got married uh
we got married september uh 2019. oh
okay and then um i had already taken the
financial peace university before we had
gotten married and i and i actually when
i took it i didn't have any debt
oh
okay now the story's coming out some
debts right just a little something just
a little bit it married into some debt
here
just 181 000 ish
i mean it wasn't a big deal
but um then i i told him i wanted to
take the class again as a couple
and and he wanted to kind of do it dave
ish
but she can't do it davish
no we took we were both full full bore
you know dave program and let's go so
wow
and decided uh immediately just change
jobs change cities everything well it
took a little bit but uh
we uh it just was the calling for us and
you know like i said it was it was
definitely divine intervention all of it
yeah well i mean you're selling stuff
buying stuff getting jobs and it's all
just lining up like a hot knife through
butter exactly
and how was that conversation when you
sat down with him and said i love you
i'm gonna marry you you owe
about about a billion dollars
and the tractors and the trucks and all
the things that a good old farming boy
is gonna say gives me my identity all
that's gotta go go
how'd that conversation go
um well i mean it was a lot of it was
like he was like well i'm i want to sell
this and i'm like are you sure because
i'm like i don't want you to have to
sell it because
i'm telling you we needed you tricked
him well
everything's got to go but oh do you
want to sell that and he said yeah i'll
sell that
no really but so it sounds like you had
the conversation and you said if i'm all
in yep i'm all in so you said like i
said jesus i trust in you that's what we
said pretty amazing that's awesome good
for you guys well done guys how's it
feel to be free awesome amazing
it's a completely different situation i
mean everything's turned upside down you
have a cash paid for a house right oh
yeah our house yeah all the way through
i mean now you got to just make a
hundred thousand dollars a year and like
save it and become baby steps
millionaires i mean my gosh you are on
your way
wow look at you guys so proud of you
thank you great that's very cool
financial peace university you have to
watch go on that class it'll mess you up
everything
it'll mess you up you'll sell your
tractor
this should be the warning sign outside
yeah just i'm just telling you don't
don't sign up for it i'm going to kill
you i'm just it's fat i mean
oh my gosh yeah so so giving yourself uh
two years later here
how different are your conversations
it no it's nothing there's no concern
about you know money i mean
obviously we're doing our budget every
month and but it's no you know anxiety
about that it's all you know raised our
our child and and just everything you
know it's it's wonderful yeah it's
awesome yeah
and is that your child in the
background doing the debt-free scream
over and over and over he's so excited
he's got it ready he knows what to do
exactly i love it all right you want to
try to put him in there or not yeah we'd
love to okay oh yes all right
181 000 paid off in 17 months making 77
to 100. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
way to go you guys
he's a lot happier now
yeah
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure
and of course
a copy of the total money makeover for
you to give away to someone and change
it all
you know it's um
interesting
that we have so much power
over our lives once we choose to yeah
people uh i mean you guys in psychology
call this locus of control but
i call it uh you know taking control
your own destiny
and
you know i could never well then you
won't then you won't that's right i i
don't know how bit well then you won't
well you know regular well then you
won't but when you just decide
an adventure we're going on an adventure
yeah
we're gonna pay off
everything yep
17 months into our marriage because we
sold
everything we moved cities
jobs we changed
every that's a lot of change right
that's a lot of anxiety it's a lot of
and i hear that a lot which is well but
but i live here and my first thought is
do you have to you don't but i i i need
my tractor because i but you don't do
you right but i got to have this
motorcycle but you don't right yeah
what's it worth to be free that's the
thing that's impossible it's okay but
there's a chance there's a trade-off
that's right there's a trade-off you
know what's it worth to leave minnesota
the number of friends
i find a couple and she says i want to
stay home and quit my job and i go well
you know uh she said i don't only need
to make about 700 a month how much is
the payment on your minivan 842 dollars
well let's just sell the minivan you
quit your job oh
what yeah yeah oh
you could choose and do it it was the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we're trying to
transform so many lives
that we mess with this toxic culture
in america today there's so much out
there that needs to be
changed in the world of mental health
and
getting the kind of job
that you need with ken coleman that
is working in your passion and hey we're
going to mess with you so much that you
start thinking of the credit card like a
cigarette of the financial world
if you want to get involved in a place
that's causing that level of disruption
we're disrupting things that mess up
people's lives
uh we got a thousand folks on our team
right now
and about half of them are technology
people right now
and so if you want to join us whatever
it is technology or otherwise we're on
the hunt we're gonna hire by 300 folks
this year and that includes
software engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front-end
technologies ux designers seo content
marking marketing specialists
data engineers data specialists
i mean and it's all over the place and
so if you sales people admin people i
mean you know if you have an interest
find out about the available jobs text
work to 33 789
now i will tell you that we work
40 hours
we work while we're at work
we we get stuff done around here but you
do go home
after you know you're at home at night i
mean we don't work 80 hours but we don't
we also don't sit around here and
play on our phone and check our facebook
you can you can walk down the hall here
you can feel it yeah it's it's when
you're here it's game on man had a
friend of mine from another state
walking through here the other day and
he goes
he goes this is everybody in here works
so hard they're all happy and i said
yeah we get rid of the other ones
it's an amazing idea yeah
so yeah if you want to join us we'd love
to have you but plan on working while
you're here and plan on going home after
40 hours which for technology people is
highly unusual because they work them 80
hours on most of these corporate gigs
and and they treat you like a freaking
robot and we treat you like a human we
actually care about people so anyway
text work to 33 789 text work to
33789 our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more always use the magic word
promo code ramsey
all right today's question comes from
ozzy in california
i'm currently taking financial peace
university with my girlfriend i've
completed baby steps one through four
and should have my current house paid
for and at one and a half years
i've also been saving for a second house
so my mom can live in my current house
when my girlfriend and i get married my
girlfriend has a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt and
recently booked a trip to visit friends
on the east coast she said that she
wants when she gets married and has kids
she won't be able to do a trip like this
so she wants to go now
my first reaction was that she should
not go on this trip because of her
student debt and when i told her this
she told me you know what you should
enjoy your money so who's right in this
situation
what do you think dave
um if you marry this girl it's gonna be
a long life i was gonna say man
y'all are not aligned
this is um
the old joke is if you marry a woman
that likes to spend money you better
enjoy making it
but that's a negative joke i mean the
same would be true opposite if you marry
a duper who doesn't earn any money you
know i mean there's
it's um
yeah you got you got a problem that's
bigger than it's this yolo problem this
i'll never be able to once i get married
and have kids my life's over i can't
hang out with my friends and so uh then
there'll be another thing there'll be
another thing no there'll be another
always yes so here's the rule okay
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
you're dating a child sir
was that what i'm i think i must be in a
mood no that sounds a little harsh i
don't think it's harsh at all i think
it's
i was kinder than i was more eloquent
than i was going to say it
um you've got well i mean i just called
his girlfriend a baby doll i mean she's
just a child but i mean it's not it's
not that's kind of harsh but yeah well
she was grown up enough to take out a
hundred thousand dollars in student
loans yeah but that just means she was
18. that's right she has a chronological
thing that doesn't hang dude emotional
maturity that's true
yeah the reality is you have lined up
your life in a way that you're almost
done paying for your house
um you're working on a second house
you're working on all your financial
house in order you're thinking about
your mom you're filling the blank and
then you've got somebody who's saying
hey you know what we got to live for
right now because the life gets awful
down the road so let's just live for the
right now yeah and those are competing
philosophical ways of doing life
see yolo contends
that tomorrow doesn't matter
because it's not guaranteed right
yolo contends
that um
yolo is rationalization
and justification
for
doing what the four-year-old child
inside of me wants to do right
that's what yolo is right
you know yolo says that if you plan for
something and save for it and pay for it
that you are no fun
because you could have just had it now
you're no fun right you're no fun
and you don't have as much fun right
well let me tell you
about my life
you know what i do now
anything i want
yes if i want to get on a plane and go
to somewhere i can just do it yeah i
mean that that's fun yes but it didn't
get there by yolo right
and so if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else but so you can't presuppose and i'm
sorry for you little children that live
in your mommy's basement and don't like
dave ramsey being a boomer and all this
crap uh but uh but the the deal is if
you want to have
a there's an adult fund and i'm not
talking about
uh
something nasty i'm talking about but a
grown grown-up fun for grown-ups
is a richer deeper kind of fun
right
you know i got seven grandkids i can
load them all on a plane and take them
somewhere right anytime i want
and that's a different thing than
i get to go out to eat whenever i want
to go out and eat because you only live
lunch and you don't have to check the
account right you don't have to
you know
i don't have to go look and see if i can
afford it that's what i'm saying there's
a piece to yeah to joy and to fun that
the yolo misses yeah yolo is about the
heart rate spike it's not about the
entire experience which is
i can sleep tonight cause i'm not
worried about it it's a
it's a roller coaster of excitement yeah
versus you're looking for a hit right
versus deep joy yeah but it's like a it
is like a drug hit you know it's a
dopamine hit and then
the you're always going to come down
from that hit so you got to do it again
you got to do it again you got to do it
again yeah so there is inside of us a
little kid that throws a fit on the
cereal aisle and wants the frosted nut
roasted nut cheerios whether you can
afford them or not and mom says no
you're four
don't throw a fit in the grocery store
because i'll bust your butt right right
but that little kid lives inside of
every one of us i want it i want it now
and then they and we say stupid stuff
like i deserve it
i've worked hard so this let me help you
with this you don't deserve nothing nope
nothing
you don't deserve nothing unless you go
get it
save up the money and pay for it and
then you can say i deserve it but you
don't deserve it because you breathe air
you entitled a little twit
oh my god
no that's just not true right it's just
not i mean
i can say that to myself because that
little kid lives inside oh he's in me
too yeah he's inside of every one of us
his name is immaturity right
and the more we don't feed that little
kid
the sooner he's not there anymore so
this happened in my life then you just
grow up in your grouchy and direct with
a guy who's a girlfriend in california
but yeah we we ordered some uh we've had
the same crummy front porch furniture
forever it wasn't your front porch
furniture it's just it might be a
hillbilly super uncomfortable right you
might be a hillbilly if and finally i
got frustrated a few weeks ago a few
months ago oh you deserve some furniture
well i thought i'm i make good money why
am i living like this and then my wife
said
because we haven't saved up and we can't
afford that yet and i was like oh yeah
oh yeah and so then we made it a
priority and then we got it
and we got it this week we have an
archer dave
it's my it's it's mine
yeah we paid for it we saved for it and
it's super comfortable yeah and now i
can sleep on it without worrying about
the payments it doesn't it doesn't
doesn't it sits different i promise you
some of your people finance your
business just think about that
just think about that right oh
how are you sleeping in a financed bear
[Music]
oh john will never be out of business
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
elizabeth starts this hour in san
antonio hi elizabeth how are you
hi i'm doing great
um
so what's going on and i actually wish i
was going to say to do my debt-free
scream i've been wanting to do that for
a long time
we are debt-free the house is paid off
the cars are paid off everything
um i am working full-time and a student
also and then
in about a year i'll go full-time
where i won't work also for nursing um
and my husband he works full-time he's
phd scientist
and then we have a 18 year old son who
has moved out and started a business you
didn't want to go to college
how can we help today
okay we just wanted to lay the
foundation so
we've got everything paid off and my
husband wants to buy an all-electric
vehicle and we were going to um save up
for it to pay cash
and currently we have two prius that are
um not the plug-in kind
and
suddenly now today he wants to go
purchase it he feels like there's a
sudden need that we need to do it now
because of everything that's going on in
the world and that
this is the time not wait so we're also
cash flow in my school and so we do have
sorry what's going on in the world that
demands that you get a plug-in vehicle
today i missed i didn't watch the news
this morning
so he feels like we um
like
potentially in the future
yeah yeah and that we would be better
off getting it now that just
are you telling me the guy has a phd and
he truly believes there's going to be no
gasoline
not no gas no just okay so we're both
very frugal and we um
so you know what is going on in the
world
that demands that you buy an electric
vehicle you said hey with all that's
going on in the world what the crap does
that mean
well that the demand for electric
vehicles is going up and that they are
harder and harder to get and there's a
long wait list for you know all the ones
that are on the market right now
um in other words i want an electric
vehicle
and i don't want to wait and i don't
want to wait and so i'm just now right
now i'm making up crap to worry about
okay so what's your household income
so our household income is about 150
five he makes 113 i make about 43. okay
and what are you gonna what are you
buying what kind of a car is he wanting
like a tesla
um so
we're between the dw uh id4 the bolt was
just recalled on friday so we can't get
that one which was much less expensive
and then our only other option really is
the tesla
okay
so let me help you with the math to
start with
you can drive that freaking tesla to the
moon and back
and mathematically you will never
justify
how much more you've spent on the tesla
than you're paying on then you then the
value of your prius
you know how much time it's going to
take you to recoup 45 000
in electric and gas savings
the rest of your freaking life
okay
so let me just tell you mathematically
this is asinine that we're using the
idea that we're saving money because
we're frugal to get an electric car
now if you want to go get a tesla
fine go get you a tesla but pay cash for
it
but you don't you don't say oh
everything that's going on in the world
and we're frugal people because both of
those things are stupid but statements
because they don't have anything to do
with reality okay that you know
everything that's going on in the world
they're making teslas you can get a
tesla i mean there's not
you know and they're not gonna be like
not able to get one and if you're not
able to get one like a delorean it that
means you didn't want one because they
went broke okay
and elon didn't make it you know but um
but the uh but if you get one which is
fine i got several friends that have
bought them um i prefer a motor but
that's okay get you one it gets you a
battery it's okay and so but but the
point is you guys make enough money to
pay cash for a sixty thousand dollar car
here's what i think in cash i knew where
you buy it
when
when our brains go to fight or flight
when we're scared
it actually has a cool bypass mechanism
in your brain that turns off your
critical thinking
part of your of your brain
because you it didn't want you sitting
at the front of a cave wondering is that
a nice tiger or is that a fluffy one a
petting tiger it just wanted you to run
or to grab a stick and go to war because
if if it happened to be a mean tiger and
you thought it was a nice one you were
going to be dead right and so it's a
cool little feature our brains have
where it trades
it trades speed for accuracy close
enough
and it sounds like you've got a husband
who loves you loves your kids
and is consuming 24 7 365 news
and he's worked himself up in a panic
and he's sitting there at home and at
home and at home and what i need to do i
need to do something and do something
and he can go down a rabbit hole that's
going to shoot him out one media
slide that's going to tell him we're
going to be out of oil it's going to be
111 a gallon it's going to be this and
that and then he's comes up with a
solution that makes no mathematical
sense rational sense climates it makes
no sense but it feels like it's the
right thing to do
and what i need that guy to do is to
close the devices
get connected to a human being
go sit down and tell somebody i'm
terrified and i'm about to make a wild
decision that doesn't make any
mathematical sense doesn't make any
rational sense
that i'm i'm not i'm not okay it's
contrary to my goals it's it's not where
i want to be the goals the goals of this
family have been to become and be debt
free and out of left field mr phd dumps
into the middle and goes
you're right his brain is completely
shut down so let's go to the devoid of
critical let's go to the end result the
end thing here let's say that we do run
out of gas dave or the gas becomes 100
i'm just having fun for a second it's
not fun and it does
having an electric car will be the your
neighbors will line up in your driveway
to shoot you if you're the only electric
car
so the world that you are predicting
that you're going to solve for is not
going to look like the world you have
now plus you have electric car so it's
okay that when i panicked i bought
bullets
i'm not saying that's okay
i'm saying that
yeah whatever yes way to go dave so what
i'm saying is
when you solve for chaos
you're solving an improbable math
problem right so what does that mean it
means you're not okay yeah your husband
spun out yeah and he needs to put the
computer down put the debit card down
and go sit down and talk to somebody
he's not okay or get some friends in his
life this is this is yeah whoo stop the
panic it's not the madness
and i'm just shaming him straight up for
his panicking
i mean for his lack of critical thinking
skills because it's just stop stop just
silly what's up everything that's going
on in the world but a drama queen you
know come on seriously
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you picture your life with no payments
maybe that's tough right now maybe
you're living paycheck to paycheck
you're worried about money chipping away
at debt
i know it's overwhelming let me tell you
when that debt's gone you know what you
get
peace
security
options
freedom the ability to build wealth
the ability to be outrageously generous
when you don't have any payments you
know what you can do anything you want
and you can do this with
financial peace university it's our
step-by-step plan that teaches you how
to save and spend wisely how to build
wealth and how to be outrageously
generous
and it comes with the every dollar
budgeting app the premium version
and you get it all with a ramsey plus
membership
nine lessons you go through the class
this is the class that's on sale right
now at a deal 30 off the 12 month
membership
for ramsey plus
and this is the class that millions and
millions and millions of people have
gone through to start your free trial
of ramsey plus
text trial
to 33
789 text trial
to 33
7
89.
so john let me ask you something
i'm thinking about that last call um
the guy who's uh wanted to buy a tesla
but i mean i've talked to people i i
remember i had a
guy that um he had this classic oh man
it was like late 60s truck and it was
perfect
antique truck
and he was a truck driver and he drove
over the road five days a week and so he
would drive his old truck
to the uh terminal
get in the 18-wheeler drive all week and
then drive his old truck home
he was in it twice a week
and he was two miles to work
so i'd go over there one day
and i had always loved this i lusted
after this old truck yes it was
beautiful it was gone he had traded it
for a brand new thirty thousand dollar
ford pickup
and i'm like dude
why did you buy any finance that of
course i'm ready to kill him what what
why why did you buy a 30 000 pickup
gas mileage was killing me
[Laughter]
four miles a week
two over
two back
for a truck payment anyway and he traded
it for i mean there's no
possible
mathematical equation you know but it
didn't weird how uh you know we in sales
we used to say people buy
emotionally and they uh
they justify intellectually so
there's that wasn't a fear-based thing
that guy was not in a panic he was not
having the world's coming to an end and
you're not gonna be able to get a tesla
thing he had not worked himself up into
a watching too much of cnn and he's lost
his dadgum mind or something it was not
that he just got
truck fever he just got a jones for it
he saw something that he wanted and he
backfilled an argument he went searching
for an argument that validated his point
he found one and it didn't
but but in his head all he was looking
for is that's different than the flight
or flight thing shutting down your
critical thinking skills no that's
that's when you go searching for a
a
a problem that backs up your answer
i need a new truck it's like jeopardy
yeah i mean i need to state the question
yeah i like that's the answer yeah i
already know the answer and i got to
state the question yeah so when we go
looking for things in the world as a
great famous quote there um whenever you
go looking for the world you will surely
find it
and so we do that with people we don't
like we do that with people we're angry
with we do that with people that we love
right
people stay in toxic relationships
because i
i'm just gonna only focus on the good
stuff and you know you'll talk to them
and they'll say well yeah he's only
cheated on me four times and he doesn't
doesn't hit me anymore
and your mouth's dropping open but i'm
i've decided i'm only going to look for
this i'm not going to look at the full
picture same with i want a new truck i
just look at that brand new truck
i can't afford that new truck and then
you start thinking
what about this truck do i not like this
gas mileage is kill and now i've painted
a picture that's gonna backfill the
thing the outcome that i want right yeah
but that's we do it all the time and
that guy might have done that instead of
panic do you think the tesla guy
potentially usually when somebody comes
home and starts laying out a case i
really like this tesla i think it's
really cool and so now i'm going to
backfill the answer
and go well the world's coming to an end
you're not going to get tesla because
the lithium and the batteries there's a
possibility you know the the slave labor
children aren't able to get enough
lithium out of the mines and so we're
not gonna be able to have batteries
there's a possibility yeah more
realistically though somebody's done
they start beautiful minding it and they
will look at this data point and this
data point and that one will stream
together and create a picture that's not
true
but that feels right and it justifies
this panicked response we got to do
something right now yeah
and then you have this poor wife who's
just going to school
the guy in the movie with a beautiful
mind's mind was not that beautiful no
that's that's the irony that's right
he was he was crazier than a bane he's
just he's struggling man but you start
pulling together disparate data points
to paint up whatever picture you want
right
and that's turn off the electronics
sometimes just stop yeah well and
it it does it it is a little bit of
affluenza
the the flu-like symptoms of affluence
uh yeah and so it's this thing if you
get the fever
i got a fever for a tesla
i mean you know how fast those things go
0-60 yeah well but but you know there's
battery shortages so you see the stuff
that's happening in the world and then
you just get stupid right and and you
just you
every one of us do i catch myself doing
it yeah um at different times in my life
but um
it's just an interesting dichotomy to me
because personal finance is eighty
percent behavior people it's only twenty
percent head knowledge i did it with you
so you have to learn to deal with the
idiot in your mirror to ever have any
freaking money i did it with a guitar
recently i've a guitar i've coveted for
years somebody i work with cody back
here
says oh man i was about to sell mine
i said well of course i got to see it so
he brings it up to the office and where
me and james have a cool little band and
we're and now now you're really coveting
and you've gone you've gone full into
biblical covenant plays better than i
could have imagined oh yeah and i'm
thinking
why do i need another guitar to cost
this much
for once a year when i actually pull it
all out and play
and how am i you know what i mean so it
just begot i i began to backfill i can
create an argument for this and at the
end of the day i have no need for this
at all none zero
none
none you walked away i walked away well
james has it now
i sold it to james yeah so i can buy it
any time
i haven't bought it yet either
but yeah it's it's we do it all the time
and that's when
the thing about affluenza is is that um
the more inputs you have
uh on your computer more hours you spend
on your computer the more hours you
spend in front of any screen television
or otherwise the more advertising that
happens
and you're getting about 4 000 to 6 000
ads a day wow if you are using a if
you're a typical consumer of television
and computer time and if you add to that
only hanging out with people who
think like you and won't or at least
don't love you enough to go that's the
stupidest thing i ever heard
if you don't have those people in your
life you just have a bunch of yes people
around you yeah bro people in your life
then you're just going to continue to
reinforce what happens right before you
do something really stupid yeah yeah
yeah bro so it's it's it's all about
surfer language yeah it's just being
able to back out of that that's why it's
something so simple like having a budget
yeah it just says
something that are facts that hold you
accountable hold you accountable it's
right and it doesn't have to be some
friend that knocks you upside the head
but it wouldn't hurt yeah but but the
you got a little piece of paper here
that says when my brain was working this
is what we agree this is what we agreed
on right oh and it's if it doesn't align
with that then possibly i need to back
up my brain might not be working is
there a gap between impulse and action
and that's what a budget gives you
that's what a friend gives you that's
what a good spouse gives you that's what
taking a walk around the block gets you
is there a space between you know wait
overnight or in in that guy's case a
minute ago he's got a good wife yeah
who's saying ah did you lose your mind
by the way we just spent all this with
you
would you go find that brain you left it
outside on the sidewalk i think
and uh you got to call each other out on
it and you go that just doesn't make
sense and if you know yourself like i
know myself i put i put barriers between
me and right yeah
and
again
we're sitting here saying that we have
both faced exactly the same stuff but i
got to tell you folks
if you the less
television and computer time you have
the less financial stupidity will be in
your life yeah because you're not
getting impacted with as much
advertising it's a pretty simple
equation
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage in person
britain and ally are with us hey guys
how are you we're doing great how are
you dave better than i deserve where do
you all live uh we're actually moving
from chapel hill up to minneapolis at
the moment oh wow yeah got a trailer out
in the parking lot i love it well just
to do a little drive by debt free screen
yeah i like it how much did you guys pay
off so we paid off 140 000 in four years
wow congrats and your range of income
during that time uh we started making
around 70 and then down to about 40 for
a while and then up to around 110. wow
okay what do y'all do for a living i
guess i've done everything from flying
drones to selling bulk fertilizer to
pest control professional yoyo
entertaining pretty much anything you
can think of wow what are you gonna be
doing in minneapolis i've actually got a
job as a maintenance director okay yeah
right and i'm a preschool teacher and um
i work with animals as well i've also
been a barn manager so cool yeah phil
you found something to do in minneapolis
already um yeah i'm currently in the job
interview process so wonderful what took
you all to minneapolis what was the
reason for going there so i grew up in
southwestern minnesota i went to college
in minneapolis and then elia grew up
just north of minneapolis and we
went to the same school there so it's
going home going home yep we only moved
down to chapel hill for a year just to
kind of get out of
the cities for a little while and
experience something new and then we're
going to be going back to the family
farm so oh wonderful good for you guys
that's fun so what kind of debt was 140
000 it was around i want to say 110 in
student loans and then a car loan on top
of that oh wow how long have you guys
been married
four years oh oh wait no we're at three
three years
the wife is the one that forgets
it's all right it's okay it's you're
kind of on the spot on the radio and
everything it's okay yeah that's that's
fine all right so
uh
you've been married about the amount of
time you've been working on this debt
okay and um
so tell me the story what made you guys
as soon as you get married you say we're
going to knock out 140 000 in debt fast
so uh for me you know we both went to
the same school it was in state but it
was not cheap um kind of went through
that whole pushing it off until later
process until we graduated
and then as graduation present my older
brother gave me the audiobook copy of
total money makeover
and i remember the note that he sent
with it said i could have bought you a
wallet i could have bought you a belt
but those things will fade away so
instead i'm going to give you something
that if you apply it it's going to
change your entire life wow he's always
been one for good advice so you know i
sat down listened to it and i remember
sitting on my bed in my parents basement
thinking this is the key to get out of
the mountain of mess that i've made for
myself
yep and he kind of dragged me along
kicking and streaming at first
i
grew up you know with a lot of medical
debt in my family and we um
just kind of i always thought like
that's just how you live is you have
debt and medical problems come up and
you can't get rid of it and
um i always say that i cry
that he saved our marriage before we
even had problems because if he wouldn't
have um got us on this path
then we would be where a lot of people
are and where my family is and
we have freedom because of him so that's
powerful that's incredible man
i love it we saved my marriage before we
even had problems yep
and let's be honest he may have sat down
and brought it to you but you you got
along the journey right yep yeah and i
guarantee you there was times you drug
him kicking and screaming probably
yeah
so how has it been you guys have been
somewhat nomadic right you lived where
everyone where you knew everybody and
that comes with its own set of
challenges and then you said forget
everybody we're moving to the woods in
the south and then you've had about
enough of that so now you're headed back
um what's it been like going back and
forth and having these conversations and
and um deciding who we're gonna be when
we're free from all this yeah well
actually this past year was probably the
best thing that could have ever happened
to us um we have always planned to kind
of leave the state for a little while
because we always knew that we would
spend the rest of our lives there but we
um up and moved last september and just
literally packed up our whole lives and
drove across the country had breakdowns
literally in kentucky and had to leave
my car there and then drive the rest of
the way and
um but if we wouldn't have moved we
actually shaved off a year of our debt
just because of the move and we
lived with nothing like we didn't even
have a microwave like we had nothing and
we saved
and like paid off all of our debt and um
it's been amazing but you also proved to
yourselves what we can live without and
what laughter and joy looks like without
all these things we thought we had to
have exactly and now you've got a new
picture that is untethered to stuff and
untethered to debt and it's just you two
taking on the world in minnesota now
yeah yeah it's been life-changing that's
incredible good for you very powerful
y'all very powerful
how's it feel to be free
it's unbelievable it's indescribable
definitely you know the past i guess
since we started taking out loans eight
years ago it just started piling up
didn't really see the end of it
um and then at the beginning of this
year i i was sick and tired before but
decided i was really sick and tired now
um so i talked to a couple of guys that
i knew that were doing handyman work you
know making 150 200 000 a year just
crushing it
and they gave me some great pieces of
advice and one of them was charge more
so uh the quadruple that i was charging
and i was getting calls day and night
you know working weekends working
afternoons after work
and i remember sitting down at the
kitchen table just adding up all the
numbers and she was in the kitchen and i
got to that final number and i said babe
we've got three thousand dollars left
and coming from where we started at 140
that it was peanuts compared to the
mountain that we started with yeah i
just have a picture of my head of you at
a birthday party surrounded by like
screaming little kids with a yo-yo just
thinking one more just one more birthday
you know we're free man you're going to
be throwing your yoyos out on the
highway on your drive back to minnesota
what an amazing journey you two
congratulations thank you yeah very well
done very well done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
i mean like most people always say it's
definitely the budget um but for us
there was something that you know you
can't explain with numbers and that was
keeping god at the forefront of our
relationship
at the beginning of this year we kind of
made a decision to to strengthen our
relationship with god and we did an
in-depth bible study every single week
you know like clockwork and looking back
on it that's exactly the time that our
debt payoff shovel tripled in size
for us that was no coincidence
yeah it's been
quite a journey with god on this way we
started our marriage that way we um
started our vows like
god is first
and then we always say family second and
work is third and we just have always
kind of trucked along that way and it
strengthened our bond and our love for
each other and i feel like
connection is one of the reasons that we
made it so if we wouldn't have pushed
each other and supported each other and
been there through all the tough times
because we've had some really rough
times these past four years but
we wouldn't be here without him and
yeah
wow
well congratulations you guys very very
proud of you you are absolute heroes
very well done and if you've done this
by now i mean the future is so bright
you guys can do anything as john said
you're so tethered to the right kinds of
things here obviously um spiritually
and but then that sets up the financial
and it sets up the careers so very very
well done we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that's the next
chapter in your story you've changed
your legacy
changed everything and a copy of the
total money makeover you can give that
away with a nice note to someone and
perfect start their journey the way your
brother started one with you that's a
great note from your brother very cool
stuff very cool
all right it is britain and ally
newly uh recently of many getting ready
to be again of minneapolis minnesota 140
000
paid off in four years making 70 to 40
to 110. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one we're dead
[Applause]
yeah
that's how they roll in minneapolis
[Applause]
powerful
very well done
you had a young couple have been married
five years you get and for those of you
who are listening you can't feel it
inspiring two old married men in this
room yeah just looking at saying wow
yeah that's what it looks like man yeah
well done guys that's very well done and
that guy's got a way cooler bigger
brother than my little brother does
i did not think
to give my little brother something that
profound
good grief
i'm gonna call him and ask for a do-over
well uh
too late great older brother
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsay personality is my
co-host today you can also join him on
the dr john dolone show email ask john
ramseysolutions.com
with your question and
kelly and the team that produces that
podcast we'll get back to you it's
monday wednesday and friday right now or
releasing those three days a week and
it's all about you calling in and asking
questions about your life your
relationship that's what it amounts to
so um same's true on this show right so
you can also leave a voicemail for john
and join that show at 8 844-693-3291
844-693-3291
now on september 18th we're going to be
doing financial peace accelerated which
means we're doing the whole
the whole curriculum in one day
so you remember like in college you
could do mini term or summers
and it was like you jam it all into one
little thing but we're gonna do the
whole thing in one day here at our
headquarters and of course we're going
to be
putting in the can some new videos to
add into financial peace university and
to replace some of the ones that are
there and if you want to be part of that
the tickets are a whole twenty dollars
uh you will be a studio audience and you
will be here in our headquarters at
nashville and so check out
ramseysolutions.com if you want to
plug into that that's the next thing and
john will be part of that i'll be part
of that
rachel will be part of that and george
campbell georgia will be part of that
we're working on that this morning i'm
excited there's some new stuff in there
that's going to be neat yeah there's a
new lesson or a complete turnover of an
old lesson but it's a update that makes
it all brand new and it's really excited
about that the one you and george are
working on i believe
yeah and that's that's going to be
excellent excellent
some of the old standards will be there
as well i'll be doing those and we're
going to be teaching all day so it's
going to be a fun day on september the
18th christopher's with us in miami hi
christopher welcome to the ramsey show
hey john hey dave how are you guys great
man what's up
well i got a question i've been
following you for years
finally got to baby step six all my
debts gone everything cars i had a line
of credit
uh all gone everything gone only thing
left is the mortgage got about
52 000 left to pay off on it
and i have about a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in savings um i'm
actually working
technically working two jobs right now
thinking of transitioning to just doing
the one working for myself full time um
so i i don't know i mean i really want
to get rid of the mortgage i want it
gone i want it dead because that's it
and then after that i'm free
um so i don't know if it's worth just
grabbing fifty two thousand dollars and
throwing it at the the bank and saying
see you later bye or
waiting it out i guess maybe it's fear
you know the the prospect of going out
on my own full time kind of scaring me
and wanting to hoard money a little more
so i would love to get your thoughts on
that
well i mean you said you've been
listening to me for years
yeah
is that that part that part was true
right
yeah you're actually the first guy when
i first got staged so you you tell me
what am i gonna say
you're gonna say to pay off the mortgage
yeah and why haven't you already yeah
[Laughter]
and listen here's the thing if you pay
it off and you get really really really
scared
and the world starts to come to an end
you can go get another mortgage
that's true if you hate being debt-free
if you wake up in the middle of the
night and go oh god i'm debt-free then
you can go get another mortgage they'll
be happy to loan you money against
something you already own and you know
what
that's never going to happen
i'll give you a money-back guarantee on
this it's not going to happen
i mean it's kind of silly you know that
right
right and so
the weird thing is is your fear should
not increase
when you pay off the mortgage it should
decrease
right
yeah true and i can't think of a better
way to go into business for myself than
already have established clients already
have an established gig sixty thousand
dollars in the bank and i don't owe
anybody anything
right yeah that was that was the goal
yeah the cash flow i kept looking at
cash flow and i said i need to be i need
to be uh you know cash rich at this
point i can't have anything tied down in
case there's ever a you know an up or a
down or whatever it is so yeah that was
exactly
i i can i can promise you this uh i have
never had in 30 years of doing the show
someone call me back and go you know
what i paid off my mortgage and it
ruined my life
it's just never happened i mean i got 22
million listeners today listen to this
conversation right now none of them are
going to call me and go you know dave
you ripped me off man i mean you just
you completely conned me on that
mortgage thing i felt so horrible when i
paid it off that i had to go get them in
the morning or just never come up i just
started a new business and i didn't have
a mortgage payment and that really
pisses me off dave
never never heard that
ever
kristen's in midland texas hi kristen hi
kirsten hi kirsten how are you
i'm doing pretty well how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um so i
um became debt-free in
april and
um about but thanks yeah i'm pretty
excited about it but uh yeah about a
month ago
i ended up having to uh i faced an
emergency and had to dip into my
emergency fund and
move to midland
and um
i'm in the process of getting my
emergency fund back up to a thousand
dollars
but i
i basically i'm trying to decide because
i have a medical
situation that's urgent that i'm facing
but i also need to be moving out in six
months
and i'm not sure should i be saving
toward both
or like focus on the medical issue
because i'm not willing to go back into
debt over my medical stuff
um
yeah
okay i i i don't under i mean
for me
medical things are because i'm a
complete coward um
they're all major
so uh
i you know i mean if you don't go do
this medical thing what happens
um like we die or i mean
no i i i mean sorry this guy
well i need about
six teeth removed um
and
it's gonna be expensive and i don't have
health insurance um
so what do you what do you what do you
make what's your income
um
i make about 18 to 28 an hour i work
mostly off of tips um
but the
uh the months that i've worked so far
i've averaged 18 to 20. so what were
your what were your dental surgery cost
um i'm not sure i'm going to be getting
the initial like what's happening with
my mouth appointment um pretty soon here
probably within a week or two okay i
want you to get two different opinions
on that
two different quotes
because it's going to be as expensive as
putting a roof on your house
and you you would get two quotes for
your roofer
and so you do the same thing with your
dentist
okay maybe three maybe three
if they're far apart okay because
i have found that the dental world is
like a lot of other worlds that the
pricing is
very
uh it's a wide spectrum
so you may find a lot of difference in
the two or three quotes so i want you to
do that
then once you have that number then you
also need to put a number down that says
what it's going to take for you to
live not where you are because you said
i have to quote move out are you with
family or something
oh yeah my um my brother who actually
kind of he's the one who helped me get
out of to get out of debt um by using
yells program um
he uh
um he's letting me rent from him uh for
six months to help me get on my feet
good very nice of it what a good guy
okay i want you to work i want you to
work all the time
as much as your body will allow you to
work and i want you to pile up as much
cash as you can pile up because i think
you can make enough to do both of these
things in six months
you have you have two goals
partying is not one of them going on
vacation is not one of them
fixing
your mouth is one of them and getting on
your feet in a sustainable situation is
one of them and you can make enough at
20 bucks an hour to do that in six
months but that's all you're you're not
gonna do anything else that's all you're
gonna do and sometimes it gets real
scary we don't have real data to work
with so get those numbers in front of
you get those numbers in front of you
and then apply your income to that and
you can see that what i'm saying is
correct
and then you'll calm down
and go do it yeah
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
theramsieshow.com and register we would
love for you to come to nashville and
tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at
825-5225
as we talk about your
relationships we talk about your mental
health we talk about your money we talk
about your life and we're gonna do it
all right in front of you triple eight
eight two five five two two five chris
is in boise idaho hi chris welcome to
the ramsay show
ah thank you how are you guys doing
better than i deserve what's up
so uh we're at we're we just recently
moved up to boise idaho and uh we're
looking to buy a house the market up
here is
crazy insane as far as
people get just trying to get into a
place so recently we found a place we
put an offer on it and we've been
offered the possibility of
passing on an appraisal
and so i just wanted to get your opinion
on
what that would look like if that's a
good idea
if it's not a good idea as far as just
knowing hey this is where it should be
it's based on what an appraiser is
saying so just wanted to get your
two cents on it okay an appraisal
is an opinion
of value
by a professional
uh hypothetically
that knows how to establish a logical
opinion of value
the way a residential appraisal is done
is
they find the three closest comparable
sales closest in geography closest in
closing date meaning they didn't close
three years ago they closed three months
ago three days ago closest in attributes
meaning you don't compare a ten thousand
square foot house with a five thousand
square foot house you compare similar
things so the closest comparables are
comparables
all right
and then you adjust for the differences
and so how many square feet is the house
that you're buying
it is 2200 square feet okay and so if
the other house was 2300 square feet
they would adjust by multiplying the per
square foot dollars by 100
and adjust that price to use it to
establish your price you follow me how
you do the adjustment yeah okay if
you're put your house has a pool and
that one doesn't they will do a plus or
minus adjustment
from the other property that they're
comparing it to and then they take those
three properties adjusted to make them
look like yours and an average of those
three adjusted
properties comparable sales is how the
appraisal is established so it's a
fairly easy process it's basically sixth
grade math with some um
with some basic application to it that
uses some common sense right now so okay
typically if you've been out looking did
you buy the house through a real estate
agent
yes okay so the real estate agent can
pull you
the three best comparables out of the
multiple listing service
that the appraiser is likely going to
use
and what he's saying is because of the
location
here in the area you kind of have a mix
of properties you have you know your
track home situations then you have
larger lots this particular piece of
property that we're buying it's it's
like two acres then that's an adjustment
to the comparable right if you're
comparing it to a track house if you
compare it to a track house that was
cheaper we would give you add on to that
track house price that sold two weeks
ago
uh because you've got two acres and he
has a a track he has a half acre
right
that makes sense but if you if you guys
change no comps in the area
there's what
there's they're saying there's no cops
in the area within because it's a it's
outside of boise so within
i get from what i've understood
those comps are supposed to come within
a certain
mileage i guess of yeah how far how far
out are you outside of boise
uh
i would say we're probably 15
15 miles oh
i mean you can get you can still get a
good feel for what this is
if the real estate agent cannot pull
something that gives you an indication
of what the value is you need a new real
estate right that's somebody trying to
sell you something
there's nothing that's comparable oh
horse crap they could give you an idea
and show you the houses i mean it might
it might be too far away to be an ideal
comp
but but at least give you an indication
of values i mean yeah i could i could
pull square footage averages across the
whole freaking city of boise and use
that as a comp and multiply that by 2200
right and i'm not going to be that's
going to tell me if i'm way off i mean
do you feel like the information you
have about the area that you're off or
you just feel completely ignorant and
vulnerable
no i just want to make sure we're not
you know we're not over we're not over
buying um and
an appraiser can't tell you that
okay okay well that's good to know
because all they're going to try to do
is what i just established
now you know and so what i don't want
you to do is pay you know
uh uh
eight hundred thousand dollars for a
property that comps out at five hundred
thousand
right then that that's my concern but i
don't again what we've seen in the area
that's not the case okay it's got
acreage that's anywhere near this
it still seems on the high side but it's
also it's a the house is built in in 19
so it's a fairly
new house as well so we're trying to
take that into consideration and i think
that's what he's getting at is there's
not going to be any exact comparables
because yeah but he needs to he needs to
give you the three best ones he can get
his hands on okay and then explain to
you what the differences are
right and let me put it this way i
bought my house in nashville i guess a
year ago now nashville has been
one of the hottest markets in the planet
and my realtor
she's amazing her name is amanda she's
an elp here several times she said we're
walking away from this because this is
not a good deal for you
and she only got paid when i bought a
house that was a realtor who was giving
me information not that was in her best
interest but that was in her client's
best interest does that make sense yeah
and here's the thing there but my point
is the appraisal
is not magical right it's not like going
to make the a bad deal it's good
appraiser for the bank them saying how
much we're gonna loan you well that it
is but i mean it's establishing value
make sure the bank is not loaning too
much right on the property and that but
but it's still not magical right
it's still not a magical document it's a
dude yeah who took three other
properties and adjusted right it's a
dude and sometimes it's not a smart dude
i've i've dealt with some of them
they're dumber than a rock and so they
drive you crazy in the real estate
business sometimes but they're not all i
mean it's not a horrible business it's a
great business most the people are very
very reasonable
but if but if you get two appraisals and
they're within five percent of each
other
that's like known as a miracle oh wow i
didn't realize it was that volatile yeah
i mean
or that much variability between yeah
absolutely so i mean and that's okay i
mean i i two appraisals on piece of
property and they're closed i can tell i
get a feel for it and i'm good yeah but
i think you can take a per square foot
on the 2200 fact you got a two acres the
fact you're out a little bit make an
adjustment and say okay this other house
is older it's on a smaller piece of
property it's internal and i'm so i'm
going to allocate a higher square foot
because of those things and you know
you're going to tell if you're if you're
hundreds of thousands of dollars off the
appraisal is not a guarantee that you're
not getting screwed
it's just not it's not a guarantee of
value it's not a guarantee of what the
market's going to do in the future it's
it's you should not be comfortable just
because of the appraisal it's an
approximation it's a it's an opinion
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
well like we were just talking about
there's a lot of hype going on in the
real estate market particularly with
buyers who think they have to buy right
now
and it's going to happen
it's got to happen right now i got to do
it right now
um a lot of this is because mortgage
interest rates have reached some of the
all-time lows and buyers are frantic to
lock in
these great rates i mean when you're
talking about something in the two
percent range that's pretty crazy you
know
three percent was pretty much gold
standard i mean my gosh and i i remember
selling real estate in the 17 market
back in the day so i mean listen
you're probably not going to get rates
cheaper than that
but that does not give you the green
light to do stupid stupid as in buying
before you're debt free buying with a no
down payment
buying with no money you know this is
going to get you ahead so get your head
out of the craziness for a second look
at your situation when are you debt free
do you have the down payment
can you afford a home mortgage mortgage
insurance taxes maintenance do you want
to do all this
i know it's easy to get caught up in
this so here's what we're going to do
we've got a free mortgage calculator
that'll help you with the process
you can plug in your numbers and see
exactly what your home ownership options
are based on your budget go to
ramseysolutions.com click free tools and
check out the free mortgage calculator
ramseysolutions.com and click free
tools there's a whole bunch of free
tools on there the mortgage calculator
is one of the more popular ones dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
today caleb is with us in winston-salem
hi caleb how are you
hey dave i'm good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um so a little over an hour ago i
actually uh drove my 2004
vehicle into a tree um and it's it
doesn't need to take much damage for it
to be totaled because are you okay
i'm fine yeah i was wearing my seatbelt
we're all good um
i'm at home
anyway i got an elp uh insurance agent
earlier this year
and now i'm just curious but like i
called my dad to
try to figure out where we go from here
and he's just saying let's just
once we get our estimate let's pay for
everything in cash and not involve
insurance
and i'm like
why did i get insurance then
um so i guess i'm just curious like what
would be the benefit of paying for it in
cash and what is
the benefit of like involving insurance
how old are you
i am 29 and i'm just figuring all this
out that's okay i want to make it fun of
you i'm just making sure you weren't
like 18 or something because
um it does affect rates right um car
insurance rates so
um i mean you should have normal car
insurance rates i do not know why you
would not turn in a wreck at 29 years
old
have you had a bunch of other wrecks
have you had some kind of violations or
something or i mean you've got like 73
tickets or
no i have a pretty clean driving record
the only time in my life i didn't turn
one in is i had an ex like uh just an
obnoxious this is 20 years ago an
obnoxious um
uh
my deductible is 2500 or something like
that or 2000 bucks and the damage to the
car was 500 bucks it was actually
cheaper for me to go pay 500 bucks than
it would be to pay out the deductible
does that make sense good point what's
your deductible
um that is a good question i don't know
um it's
yeah i don't know
so i'd find that out well i mean i did
look up the kelly blue book value and
it's like hundred dollars in my vehicle
so
okay so if you have a thousand dollar
deductible
then you may be in the category of what
john's talking about and the insurance
company is going to write you a 900
check for your loss of your well if you
have a thousand dollar deductible and
the car is worth 1300 you're gonna get
300 bucks and your premiums are going to
go up for turning in iraq right on the
next thing so your dad in that case
would be right
okay yeah you would just say because
you're gonna if you got a thousand
dollar deductible the first thousand of
the thirteen hundred is out of your
pocket right
yeah and so um you're hoping they give
you the full the kbb value of that but
if you have a 250 deductible you turn it
in right
okay because they're gonna give you an
eleven hundred dollar check then right
yeah i guess i have some homework to do
then yeah you call have you called your
agent oh no because your dad's not yet
yeah yeah yeah you need to you need to
gather some information and your agents
not
um uh
you know if you if you're working with
an elp to get insurance that means they
shop to several different insurance
companies so they don't work for the
insurance company say they work for you
they're an insurance broker and so they
can give you good advice on this
but if you had if you had a state farm
you called the state farm agent they
have to turn they have to tell state
farm everything so the good news here is
these guys this guy's on your team
and so
my guess is you've got a 250 or a 500
deductible and my guess is you probably
need to turn this wreck in because you
probably don't have a lot of money to go
buy another car with
no i'm in baby step two i got a thousand
dollars okay so
yeah so i'm hoping you did not take a
thousand dollar deductible on this car
i don't you shouldn't i wouldn't assume
so yeah you shouldn't have you probably
have a 250 which would be fairly
standard so you're going to get 1100
1200 bucks out of the insurance company
and you're going to put a little bit of
your thousand with this because this is
an emergency and you're going to go buy
a 1500 car
okay with some insurance money
i think that's what's going to happen
okay and then you're going to have to
stop your baby step two and get your
thousand dollar bill back up to a
thousand again
and you know then we're gonna go forward
from there the great news is nobody's
hurt yeah i'm glad you're okay man yes
thank you thank you scares the crap out
have you done it
yes i'm still kind of shaking a little
bit yeah like adrenaline adrenaline dump
yeah it may take a few hours but yeah
yeah your hands shaking a little just
from the the thing yeah i was i was
going to the farm friday morning i come
around this corner down here dead gum
raptor goes completely sideways oh just
spun out i just about whipped it all the
way around yeah and it just gotten it
was been raining and man my heart starts
beating right now just remembering it
yeah it's a anytime you have that
this is this is not fun about to tear up
a good car here yeah i'm sorry man i'm
sorry you've been through that but i i
think you probably have a low deductible
if you had a high deductible i think
your dad would have been right and he
probably carries a high deductible which
is probably he's able to and is a more
expensive car and he's more of a
situation like john had well and and
also remember when you know if you get
in a single car accident like this you
may have a ticket and you have to pay to
have the thing towed so there's going to
be some money coming out of your
emergency fund too so make sure you do
it all the right way and get all your
info information right yeah because the
car's definitely totaled yeah
i mean if you bumped it it's 1300 bucks
you totally that's right it didn't take
much
all right gabriel is with us in san
antonio hi gabriel how are you
i'm doing outstanding how are you better
than i deserve what's up
i need words of wisdom from you sir um
i currently have uh three properties
one's a commercial property
that one's paid off and then i have a
residential house it's also paid off and
then
the current house i live in i stole the
mortgage on it so less than half on it
for
being there for less than three years i
only go 143 i built it for 320
and now about 143 000. what do you make
of here
between me and the wife um
ballpark i'll say a lot closer to
between 250 and 300 000.
so how quick you're going pal 140
i'm sorry how quick making that kind of
money you're going to pay off this 140
000 mortgage
um
just depends how the business responds
so far the business has been doing
pretty good
i think so you're making a quarter
million dollars a year
yes sir between 100
i also have three professions i'm a i'm
a first responder and i'm also an
electrical and mechanical uh contractor
yeah
that's awesome man you're making a lot
of money you should pay i mean you make
250 a year you should pay this off in a
year and a half two years shouldn't you
that's that's my intent but you know we
we have we have some expenses like you
know private school for the kids and
dude you make a quarter of a million
dollars uh yes sir but
you know the what i was thinking of
doing not only this is the wife's
decision or not
you know the the house i have in the
southeast of san antonio it's a small
two-bedroom house that
that i had when i first you know just me
and myself i was sitting with that for
nine and a half years so i i fixed that
house up and i made it nice it looks
real good and
my fellow officers was also a realtor
look if you want to sell it fine you can
sell it you don't have to sell it you do
have to get on a budget because you
don't know where all your money's going
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage juan and anna maria are
with us hey guys how are you hi hi hello
welcome welcome where do you guys live
carter
georgia all right a little north of
atlanta all right welcome to nashville
and all the way up here to do a debt
free scream how much have you paid off
we paid 91
898
in two years and two months wow
and your range of income during that two
years
we start at 75 thousand and right now we
are in 152.
at 152. great what do you guys do for a
living i'm a videographer
and i am a technical director for a
dietary supplement company wonderful
good for you guys well congratulations
what kind of debt was the 92 000
yeah uh it was a ton of stuff it was
three credit cards it was a personal
loan and
medical bills and
uh student loans okay wow
okay how long you guys have been married
five years all right so what happened uh
halfway into the marriage two years ago
two months ago
you looked down and you went ah
yeah me yeah okay so i had an emergency
surgery where we were told that we were
going to have to do
fertility treatments in order to
start our family
we kind of freaked out and of course i
had
done my master's and i had finished that
up and we had student loans and we had
that grace period so i was like yeah we
can pay it off later
um but when we started figuring out
fertility treatments and ivf and all
these things i kind of freaked out and i
said we have to do it we have to do it
we have to do it and um
we kind of
at the time we didn't have the income
that we have now
um
and we were kind of struggling with him
being in a couple of jobs and not one
specific job so we were just basically
living off of my salary and i decided
let's just do it it doesn't matter we'll
get into this 35 000 loan
whatever interest rate it doesn't matter
we'll just have to do it um i was
listening to you at the time
and uh i'm not gonna cry i told myself i
wasn't gonna cry and uh um
i was listening to you at the time and i
remember um
you know you saying well save up for
certain things that you want to do but i
was like you know i kind of shut you out
for a little bit and i didn't want to
listen to it anymore
but
we actually went through the ivf
treatment and it didn't work and i
remember just being so devastated that
it hadn't worked and now we were sitting
there having to pay
every month a 900
monthly payment that was just a monthly
reminder that it hadn't worked
so um amazing
that's so hard yeah you're doing good
wow yeah
so
um
i told him i just i want to get rid of
this loan because it's just a monthly
reminder of how bad things were for us
and
um if you can't tell by his accent yeah
from we are from colombia i moved here
five years ago and i thought east
tennessee for sure
i was way off yeah i really like a
colombian
it's different and
yeah has been like um difficult of
course but
um hard work and um
know that
everything will be better
and working harder as a team because we
are a team so yeah so
35 000 of the 92 was the ivf
okay and so just the weight of that
emotionally made you guys go yeah we got
to pounce on this i have to get this out
of my face it's driving me nuts exactly
we were not gazelle intense after that
monthly payment started kicking in and i
told him i don't want to think about
this every month is just and i think um
after that i started again listening to
your show and just
reading again and making our budget and
doing all these things and then in one
of your shows
i don't remember if it was you or
somebody else but you said you know if
you're doing ivf go for it stop whatever
else you're doing but make sure you save
up and you pay cash so that you don't
have that monthly reminder in case it
didn't work that it didn't and i was
like yep and whenever i go and step on
that stage and tell people about how
we're debt-free i'm going to tell them
definitely
um
pay it as as
like right up front don't do loans it's
just it's a horrible reminder but we're
here there's so much drama involved in
the whole process anyway yeah and uh on
top of that and the you know you're
waiting and you're waiting and you're
waiting did it take you know and and
then the disappointment and the stuff
and then you add to that the slap in the
face of the debt payment it's just too
much yeah it's just definitely a lot and
then you know the the student loans for
the master's degree i mean
it's gotten me where i am today uh
career-wise but i could have definitely
taken a different route for that but
but you're how old
i'm 32 i just turned 32 last week oh
happy birthday thank you so you've got
plenty of time yeah plenty of time for
this all to work out and it will
uh for sure
and uh so so then you jump on this with
both feet at this point and you go okay
we're gonna we're gonna actually do this
ramsey stuff i'm actually gonna go
gazelle intense and we're not gonna do
anything and we're getting this whole
thing paid off and two years and two
months later you're done
proof that when you do lean in on it it
goes yeah yeah i'm proud of you guys
thank you so proud of you guys how's it
feel to be free good amazing yeah yeah
well done have you had your first month
where you've got no bills and that 150
000 has just deposited itself yeah so
what we did is we got married and since
basically we met in colombia i brought
him here
we got married while he was doing his
whole immigration status change i was
basically
taking care of the house and we didn't
have a big wedding and we didn't have a
honeymoon so as soon as we paid it off
we scheduled our little honeymoon to
cancun
and so it was nice to kind of know that
it was already paid for we had nothing
to worry about and we didn't have to
worry about coming home to all these
bills and anything
that's so good
that's so good you deserve a celebration
that's peace yeah that's neat yeah
that's incredible good for you guys
thank you thank you
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of daddy
teamwork yeah work hard and
know that you have that
reward on the end of your journey
for sure
it pays off it pays off it may look like
you're not ever getting there and
a reminder
i wanted to send him back to colombia so
many times
he stopped at marsh too it was it was
but definitely now we get to enjoy each
other and just we sit at home and we
watch our soap operas or telenovelas in
spanish
and we just enjoy it we enjoy it and we
enjoy our fur baby and and our nephews
and everything and we it's so nice to
just we are able to help and that's huge
that's huge for us it's been it's huge
for me and for him too but um that's
rewarding for me is just knowing that
you can help others
after you're done with your journey yeah
well you're not done
you're you're 32. but you got this part
of it done you got this part of it done
and there's a lot to a lot of upside a
lot of wonderful things are going to
happen in the next decade
of your lives is going to be absolutely
amazing i predict so proud of y'all well
done
very very well done very powerful
wow
90 well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because of course that
is the next chapter in your old story
for sure is the legacy that you're
building and a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and get
somebody started so
juan and anna marie from cartersville
georgia the atlanta area 92 000 paid off
two years two months making 75 all the
way to now 152 what a powerful story
incredible count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
[Applause]
they are fun
my gosh that's wonderful that east
tennessee accent coming through
what a couple of
what incredible couple i love it i love
it i love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 41 10
so do not fear
for i'm with you
do not be
dismayed
for i am your god
i will strengthen you and help you
i will uphold you
with my righteous right hand
brian tracy said character is the
ability to follow through on a
resolution long after the emotion with
which it was made
has passed
oh we are in need of character
in our culture today
stephanie is with us in arlington
virginia hi stephanie welcome to the
ramsay show
hello
hi
hi um so i am a
first-time caller but big fan of the
show
i am calling to get some advice i'm a
first-time homebuyer and i went in
uh
the deep end for my first buy
i've been renting ever since i graduated
college and i am at 28 officially as of
june and
i
ended up going into a large investment
and i'm just kind of looking to get
advice in terms of liquidating my assets
and my savings
hoping to do this without any of my
parents help um but they are offering um
and unfortunately crypto is not an
option which i had actually spent some
time learning and investing in um and
thought that would be an option to sell
my crypto but it sounds like freddie mac
and and such have not made legislation
that allows me
to use that but um
i i ended up selling all my employees
stock purchase put
my employee stock
which got me about half of the down
payment from my home
which is only 10
of the
actual loan
and the other half i'm looking at
my 401k
and the first thing i found when i
looked up um in terms of getting a 401k
loan your show popped up in terms of not
getting ever getting a 401k loan
i am able to take about 60k in cash or
the limit of 50k and alone but i was
curious to just get your opinion in
terms of
um the remaining uh 50k that i would
like to liquidate
um
what would you suggest
knowing that i have um the 401k
and i'm happy to answer anything i got a
little bit lost in the process so you're
buying a home you want to buy a home
you
did all the home inspection and now it's
just in terms of uh and you have you
have 10 down from the sale of employee
stock
um yeah so in terms of the um
the mortgage
so
it was i'll just tell you the numbers it
was um 760 is what we closed on um and
you've already closed on it
just stopped a second i don't want to
hear all that that the bottom line is
you have 10 of your down payment you
have not closed yet in the bank from the
sale of employee stock correct
yes or no yes or no i need
no i am still working on getting that 10
percent i want to get 100
okay so how much do you have from the
sale of the employee stock
employee stock i have 55k 55k all right
and so you could do a fannie mae loan
with five percent down with that on a
15-year fixed what is your house what is
your income
my income is about 130. okay all right
so you can probably pull this off
um
you have no other savings at all other
than 401k and you said you own some
crypto
yeah and i put down the 14.5 initial um
with just the cash that i had and that
was it
you taught your earnest money check
what was that well you put down 14 500
as earnest money on the contract yes yes
yes all right so 55 and you have no
other money you have zero emergency fund
um i
i do have another
td ameritrade stock
that i could sell or get what does that
work pre-cash what's that i could i
could pull out 23. it's 55 total but it
is
i could only access 23 without the
double uh it's a roth r ira so i would
get double tax though
we don't cash out roth iras and we don't
cash out 401ks we don't borrow on 401k
so why is it why is it you're not
cashing out your crypto
um it sounds like in terms of sourcing
um and trusting where that cash comes
from banks are not recognizing it in
terms of a down payment
no but if you sell your crypto and you
don't have the cash sell the crypto
what's it worth
um i have about 30k and krypto
today
um
i believe there was an issue with with
that it needs to be on the books for
about two months
uh not no you you don't have you have
enough down payment to close on the deal
now
you just don't have enough that you want
you can you can do a 95
conventional fannie mae loan you have
five percent down
so you can do that but you're wanting to
put 10 percent down and we're trying to
help you get there plus you don't you
have no money
that you can get to except retirement
accounts and you're going to get penalty
you're going to get your butt penalized
off okay you're too broke you're too
broke to buy this house way too broke to
buy this house but you've already
contracted for it you shouldn't have
bought it
because you've got all your money stuck
in it okay you gotta cause you don't
have any money you have no money you're
broke
i mean all your money's tied up in
retirement accounts and
other things so anyway the
the deal is that um
uh uh uh
yeah i want you to have an emergency
fund in place a rainy day fund and i
don't want you
i i don't care but i'm saying what i
would advise you to do
because if i were in your shoes and woke
up you need to close on this deal you
put down earnest money you made a
promise you've made a pledge called a
contract to buy this house and so yeah
you need to cash out your crypto today
to be able to follow through on this and
and whatever and you need to have 20 000
cash in the bank after you close on this
house do not close on this house and put
every dime you have into it because as
soon as you move in crap's going to fall
in
you're going to need a new roof and
you're asking for trouble you're asking
for trouble being broke and buying a
house
and so uh it's not a blessing to buy a
house when you're broke you just got the
28 year old fever i gotta have a house
this is a three-quarter of a million
dollar house and you do make 130 grand
which feels like a lot but you bought a
three-quarter of a million dollar house
with no
money yeah so broke your 401k and your
roth ira does not count because you
cannot get to that without penalties and
taxes you start cashing this stuff out
you're gonna get hit with a 10 penalty
plus your tax rate so you're gonna get
hit with 40 percent dave i want to
borrow money at 40 interest to buy this
house
i would say no don't do that that
doesn't sound wise
and that is exactly what i'm sure
wouldn't take out a mortgage for 40 yeah
right interest
geez nuts and but i'm keeping my
freaking crypto and i know it's cool
yeah to sit at some cool hipster bar and
be like oh i got crypto you're broke
sell it
typical crypto investor put 30 000 cash
under your pillow for crying out loud
yeah yeah you need you need to put 20
000 bucks in the bank and put the other
10 000 the crypto with the 55 and put a
65 000 down payment on this house and
close on it yeah and for god's sake put
it on a 15-year fixed and then get a
six-month emergency fund
20 000 and start building up your
emergency fund there
so yeah
i don't even
it's off man
it's um
it's just what we talked about in
another segment it's just you get this
picture in your head and you start
getting this fever and all of a sudden
i'm gonna do this and move that and sell
that and hold on to this and
all these competing pictures when you
collide when you force a deal yeah you
always do a bad deal man and you're
forcing this one for sure
but yeah you had a whole bunch of stuff
going on you need to clean up here
anyway so that's good you have the stock
options you need the employee stock
options you need to clean up you need to
clean up the crypto and you need to get
over and now you can sit down build your
emergency fund start doing your uh
investing steadily into building some
wealth in your 401k once your emergency
fund's in place
and quit screwing around with the rest
of this stuff yeah still mess with it
you just it's not going to get you where
you want to go yeah but hey thank you
for the call and i hope that helps you
john deloney dr john dolone good show
today and also with you
james childs
kelly daniels great work i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you